the nostalgia critic ah yes I remember
that boy I met him one day when I was
walking down the street trying to find
random people to partake in a gravy orgy
surprisingly not too many people were
green to it however he came across my
path and asked me a certain question he
said he was looking for a place where he
could find some insane drunk people to
ramble on about anything because
apparently that got a lot of views
online and I said to it that's a very
good question even though technically
that wasn't a question
but nevertheless I pointed him in the
direction of a certain bar that was
right down the street so I'm sitting the
turn Iqbal when in walks this bloke all
the nostalgia critic
aren't you gonna cut to me drawing a
picture or something nah okay so anyway
look this way oh sorry so anyway he
comes in I says he's looking for some
drunken people that he can expose on his
internet website doesn't some websites
on the Internet
so redundant but anyway so he says that
he's looking for some folks that can
make asses of themselves because
apparently that gets a lot of views
awesome well you could try out the other
most the stories that people say are
more depressing that they are funny or
even that entertaining
not set to a man said if you're looking
for someone I can really really
genuinely just go all I'll be very
entertaining kind of sad too but
entertaining the son who's constantly
begging for money outside mr. McCready
approached me while I was in the process
of relocating from a bag of ramen
noodles to eight boxes soy milk and he
said that he was interested in finding
someone who was intelligent and
sophisticated well I said I'd be very
interested in your offer but what would
I be able to talk about he said movies
and I of course had to think about frog
a whole zoo seconds I'm not talking
about movies but more especially I like
being a war more building but the part
that got me especially excited it is
when he said that he was going to pay me
an unbelievable amount of money I
understand he's a compulsive liar that
of course was a lie I can totally relate
to that oh yeah it wasn't very nice to
that homeless man he is a liar the devil
is a liar probably should have
introduced them he says that he pays me
in breathing air but the more I think
about it that stuff is probably pretty
cheap so then it comes up to me and he
was wondering if I would like my own
show and I said well I don't really
think I have a very uh you know
straightforward face for internet um but
then again he said ah I think it's okay
you know looks a little similar to mine
but I don't think anyone would be able
to tell I never get any questions of
people asking me whether or not we're
related or why we look so much alike not
at all it's not like that's the one
question that keeps popping up every
single week I look inside my email box
that I just want to grab him and strike
11 shout out I asked my critic was a
persuasive man he was very good at
fooling me into coming along with him on
adventures such as for the Necronomicon
which just saying that name makes me
piss my
sorry I understand his fashion sense
wasn't very good like he wanted to look
professional at first but then decided
not to a lot of people may remember him
as a cold cynical dark man I remember
him as far worse so I'll guess I gotta
give him some credit on me if it wasn't
for him I wouldn't be telling you all
these stories my fashion sense on the
other hand has always been phenomenal I
stole this off the court of Hugh Hefner
I know for some reason Lee's video game
characters never catch all never to tell
me there's don't they know there's a
website I I digress now I know what
you're thinking Hugh Hefner isn't dead
yes he is whenever I think of the name
dystocia a critic I always associate it
with pain and lack of feeling in my
genitals that's just a zombie walking
around I remember one of the more tragic
things to come out of their conversation
was he took a look at Lake who was
sitting in the corner and asked how do
you think I look at a green skirt I said
I think you look horrendous do you think
any man who makes a living that way
would actually survive in this world
without some crazy man going jealous and
assassinating him of course not thank
God that introduction to him suddenly
turned that mental image into a
horrifying actual image that will never
leave our memory
I suppose I shall apologize for that I
did marry one of his bun Easter oh not
the attractive women one of his actual
bunnies he had actual bunnies why is
everyone always shocked by that he just
opened up his legs we could see
everything I mean I'm still seeing a
therapist what I remember most about mr.
McCready was my extreme lack of love for
a human being I never encountered that
until I met him my mother not a strange
thing is that he comes up to me he says
our Auto a nostalgia critic special I
said what's a nostalgia critic specially
says well you know that drink that's
mostly alcohol it's illegal in most
everywhere that has breathing people I
said moonshine I you said yeah I do
remember telling him that I was not
interested in working with him unless
you know there was some form of payment
so he said that there was this magical
moon drink that we changed my mind
so the nostalgia critic and that
homeless man come in both getting
totally sauced up on moonshine I did
that man even need moonshine he looked
like he was on moonshine 24/7 it looked
like his blood was clear because of it
moonshine is my new water I think it
actually takes up more of my body than
actual water in that it will certainly
get rid of the water I know was supposed
to be talking about the nostalgia critic
but I'm sorry I'm going to talk about
you have know some more the last image I
remember of him was him and that
homeless man swinging across the
chandelier singing cocktails did you
know that his dick is literally a raisin
I remember mr. me critic wanted to go
back into the bar while we were hyped up
on moonshine fiddle band oh it's a
raisin and said he wanted to play Donkey
Kong swinging efficient earlier Hey Hey
which was kind of strange see how Donkey
Kong was actually there and he was much
more behaved
I remember that homeless man rather slow
Pikachu I remember smoking this huge
Twinkie with eyes as all to watch and
all they would ever say is Pikachu pick
at you
and I'm like we're in the entertainment
business there's Jews everywhere you
have no raped me
he was kind enough when we were rotting
cold and shivering in that prison cell
to give me first to the men who thought
that we were very attractive that was
very nice of him then the statue critic
did not rape me
I give him kudos for that something
tells me the less I know about that
individual the better I guess in the end
of the day all I can really say is yes
he deserves to die I hope he burns it
hell please tell me no more about that
individual